in Lebanon there have been clashes
between Hezbollah supporters and
anti-government protesters in Beirut the
scuffles prompted riot police to
intervene to try to defuse the situation
similar confrontations broke out on
Thursday night at the same site in the
center of the city hundreds of thousands
of people have been demonstrating now
for the past nine days in a televised
address Hezbollah leader Hassan
Nasrallah said the fall of the
government could lead to civil war
Stephanie Decker has more from Beirut
the ninth day of these protests and
we've seen some trouble already hit the
protest areas we had a group of men who
supported Hezbollah enter the square in
front of the government palace which is
just a couple hundred meters away from
here they started throwing stones and
sticks there were injuries among the
protesters it was very tense people were
very scared the police on the ground
riot police tried to separate the two
sides but this is one of the fears that
protesters I'm happier than the
political parties will start to send
their men down to the streets to make
trouble now Hezbollah has distanced
themselves with these men we have heard
from her son the son of the leader of
Hezbollah he spoke earlier today his
voice boomed out over the microphones
here and everyone listen to what he had
to say this is
mainly under the current monetary and
economic situation and the fragile
political climate in all of the
targeting that is happening
internationally and regionally void will
lead to chaos void will lead to
destruction well the reaction here from
the protesters is not welcoming that
speech particularly when he said that
there were foreign hands involved all
speak the protesters who is behind
funding them so many people are not too
happy in terms of the protesters about
his message we're not afraid of all the
messages of fear and threat that has
been promoting we're determined to say
on the streets and did we achieve our
demands what was interesting for the
first time behind her Centinela was the
Lebanese flag not the flag of Hezbollah
clearly sending a message that he is a
Lebanese leader and on one often even up
myself
admission funded by Iran is a very
difficult and unpredictable time said
Lebanon yes they are unprecedented yes
the receive Korea and hope of the
streets but what happened here in the
squares when you see the confrontation
between been supportive of those
political parties and they remain many
of them will show you why people are
concerned about the way for the message
from his mother's leader was it's not
time to move this government is of
course the
powerful political and military force in
this country at the moment we're in a
stalemate the government isn't standing
down the protesters are not leaving it
is uncertain which way this is all going
to go